deu and bakugo are finally fighting
together against shigaraki and all for
one all might's life is on the line and
that means that deu and bakugo have to
work together to create a new world
breaking Power by combining their
overpowered quirks we are so close to
the Epic ending of the entire mha series
and that twist at the end was amazing so
let's get into it you guys know how this
works if you enjoy my mha videos and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now for
that YouTube algorithm and if you want
to help this channel awaken the true
power of its Quirk by hitting 2 million
subscribers do me a big favor and
subscribe right now finally this video
will of course contain Boku no hero
manga spoilers so please proceed with
caution you have been warned in the last
chapter we saw that all might's attempt
to sacrifice himself by exploding his
Gauntlet in Al for one's face failed and
so the villain is still alive but on the
bright side so is all might we also
witnessed the shocking return of bakugo
as the narrator announced a new
beginning for the first time in an
incredibly long time both deu and bakugo
are together on the same Battlefield and
they are about to fight the final
villains all for one and chaki as a team
oh and did I mention that all might is
still alive he is horribly injured and
all for one is literally holding him up
in his arms and can kill him at any time
but nope he decided not to kill him yet
I'm sure he definitely won't come to
regret that later the latest chapter
begins with yet another reminder of
night ey's prophecy about all might's
death and this is at least like the
third time we've been reminded about
this prophecy since the fight between
all for one and all might started the
point that hosi is making here is that
all might definitely believes that this
is the villain that night ey was talking
about night ey might not have realized
that this was all for one because of how
young he looks now but all might is
convinced that young all for one is the
villain at whose hands he is supposed to
suffer a gruesome death we are then
again reminded that many people
throughout the world are watching this
fight alive some are already moving on
to other things because they don't think
that the events on the other side of the
world really affect them but then we see
that extremely attractive weather girl
Merill I believe she first appeared in
chapter
374 and back then she was talking about
the butterfly effect the idea that a
single small event can eventually lead
to something massive happening like a
butterfly flapping his wings in one part
of the world and eventually this leading
to a massive hurricane in another part
of the world the point of the meril
appearance here is to emphasize that
even though some people are giving up
and losing interest in the fight there
are still many others who are watching
and rooting for the heroes and who don't
want all might to die however the
butterfly effect that Hoshi is alluding
to here is not related to weather
patterns but to the idea that even small
acts of support for the heroes could
turn into a game-changing force down the
line we then see shigaraki looking
surprised as bakugo leaps off the
floating UA and heads right for deu when
he arrives Deku grabs bakugo's hand with
his left hand while still holding
shigaraki up with black whip in his
right hand and that is when Deku decides
to use gearshift once again the second
user even warns him that if he does this
the kickback will be even worse and it
will be as good as giving up on Victory
but obviously deu is never going to
listen to reasonable advice when he has
an opportunity to s sacrifice his own
body and so Deku uses gearshift to throw
bakugo at all for one and all might at
incredible speed in a desperate attempt
to save toshinori shigaraki is skeptical
though and he tells Deku that bakugo
will never make it on time all might is
already as good as dead in fact the
silhouette of his vestage within one for
all is no longer looking like it used to
a formless silhouette now that
silhouette is starting to look like the
real toshinori which means that almost
might is dying and he is about to join
the other dead vestiges in the one
forall Afterlife by the way I'm assuming
that shigaraki knows this because he is
also connected to one for all through
all for one shigaraki is absolutely
loving this because he has always hated
all might all might was the hero who
brought dreams to this world that is to
say he is the hero who contributed the
most to the image of the hero society as
this idealistic and peaceful place but
as we know shigaraki's experience with
the hero Society was very different so
he resents all might and everything that
the symbol of peace stands for but back
to bakugo he is already moving extremely
fast through the air thanks to deku's
gearshift but he then increases his
speed even further by using his own
Quirk to propel himself even faster we
are then introduced to the fact that in
the world of mha even thoughts possess a
sword of energy an energy that strives
for a certain future an energy that
comes from wishing for a certain future
and as we see hundreds and thousands of
people watching the fight and wishing
and praying for all might to be rescued
night ey's prophecy seems to have
changed as he flies by at unbelievable
speed bakugo sever both of all one's
arms and takes possession of all might
he then blasts off past the villain and
it seems that the future has been
changed as a surprised all might calls
out to bakugo his vestage Within one for
all goes back to its normal silhouette
form this means that all might is not
dying all might will not die at the
hands of all for one bakugo and deu just
changed night ey's prophecy just as deu
was able to do earlier in the story and
it seems that the power of everyone's
wishes and prayers contributed to this
as well I guess that's kind of like the
power of friendship but on steroids
since everyone in the world could
potentially contribute to it I'm not
sure how exactly this sort of power of
Wishful Thinking can be used to
essentially alter Destiny but let me
know down in the comments how you think
this works can the power of Wishful
Thinking by a large number of people
actually change the future in mha and if
it can is that actually a problem for
the plot is this just the power of
Friendship on steroids or do you think
that it makes sense in that world do you
think this is actually bad fighting or
do you like the idea let me know down in
the comments the chapter ends with a
panel of bakugo screaming we'll win this
and man there is a lot to unpack here
all might's death has seemingly been
averted bakugo is back in the fight and
he just relieved all for one of both of
his arms and deu was able to effectively
combine his gear shift with bakugo
squirk in order to pull off an
incredible rescue does this mean thatu
is able to use gear shift without
worrying about those negative side
effects that the second user keeps
talking about or is his overuse of The
Quirk going to catch up to him
eventually and is deku's quirk teamwork
with bakugo only the beginning of Quirk
combinations and fusions in this final
battle as we know in the second mha
movie Heroes Rising deu is able to share
the power of one for all with bakugo
allowing bakugo to temporarily use one
for all in order to defeat the
overpowered villain nine Deku does this
by initiating the process of
transferring one for all to a successor
in this case bakugo just like all might
did with him even after initiating the
transfer to bakugo deu himself was still
able to use those Embers of The Quirk
that all might was able to use long
after giving his Quirk to deu and so we
got to see both deu and bakugo using one
for all together and the ensuing battle
against nine was absolutely freaking
epic they wreck nine with joint attacks
like the absolutely epic tag team
Detroit Smash and although Deku believes
that after this he will lose the ability
to use one for all because he
transferred it to bakugo after the fight
is over the vestages themselves decide
that Deku will keep one for all even
though he tried to transfer it and so
bakugo only got to use it temporarily
and then Deku gets it back the movies
are of course their own self-contained
stories but the concepts and characters
from the movies often show up in the
manga later on for example Melissa
Shield has been showing up quite a bit
in this final Arc and she was first
introduced in the first mha movie so if
we know that deu can temporarily
transfer the powers of one for all
itself to another user like bakugo it is
certainly possible that he could do
something similar to this again during
the final battle against all for one and
shigaraki in fact now that he's unlocked
all the quirks of the former users like
gearshift and black whip deu might be
able to temporarily transfer these
quirks onto others as well and then
combine them with the original quirks of
those people that he is sharing his
quirks with and although deu may share
one for all with bakugo once again
there's no reason why he couldn't
potentially share it with even more
people maybe even all of class 1 a which
would mean that one for all has truly
lived up to its name one for all and the
students have lived up to their claim
that this story is how they all became
the greatest heroes if de was able to
share all of his quirks within one for
all with other people like bakugo I
wonder if entirely unique Fusion quirks
could appear as a result of this sharing
like for example combining explosion
with one for all and gear shift and
float and fudg in and black Whip and
smokees Screen could be so insane it
could create something like the
equivalent of a flying volcanic eruption
an absolutely epic Fusion super Quirk
like this could definitely be the thing
that finally takes down awaken shigaraki
once and for all what do you guys think
will Deku and bakugo continue to fight
as a team and could Deku share one for
all and even his other quirks with
bakugo and the other students will we
see the birth of a new Earth shattering
Fusion Quirk can you think of any cool
Fusion quirks that could be created by
combining deku's quirks with the quirks
of some of the other class 1a students
if you're looking for another
imaginative mha video to watch next
check out my video on what would happen
if deu became the main villain of the
mha series link on screen and in the
description if you enjoyed this video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like right now and if you
want to help this channel awaken its
Quirk by hitting 2 million subscribers
do me a huge favor and subscribe right
now